there is nothing save the selfish heart of man
that lives unto itself no bird that cleaves
the air no animal that moves upon the ground
but ministers to some other life there is no
leaf of the forest or lowly blade of grass but
has its ministry every tree and shrub and leaf
pours forth that element of life without
which neither man nor animal could live
and man an animal in turn minister to the life
of tree and shrub and leaf the flowers breathe
fragrance and unfold the beauty and blessing to
the world the sun sheds its light to gladden a
thousand worlds the ocean itself the source of
all our springs and fountains receives the streams
from every land but takes to give the mists
ascending from its bosom fall in showers to water
the earth that it may bring forth and bud the
desire of ages page 20 paragraph two god is good
and all the time the message of that quotation
is simple and at the same time profound and it
is also otherworldly in god's system everything
that exists exists to serve something else
nothing was made for its own sake
the system of the world is precisely
the opposite i exist for me
god's system is i exist for
you and you exist for me
as i contemplate the reason
for my presence in this place
and i feel highly honored to be here to be a
part of this first graduation of pure light
pure light is an institution and god knows i
speak the truth for which i pray constantly
i met some of the original founders i visited
the place a couple years ago and i have
this interest in the welfare and the success
of pure light and so i pray and i ask god
all the time to bless pure light so i am
singularly honored to be a part of the first
graduation i have entitled
my remarks a labor of love
i realize some of your recording just make
sure your phones do not ring you don't need
sound to record favor number two while i'm
speaking ask god to put his words in my mouth
my words have no power god's words can change your
lives jeremiah 1 verse 9 then the lord put forth
his hand and touched my mouth and the lord said
unto me behold i have put my words in thy mouth
and i also want you very
earnestly to think as you listen
isaiah 1 18 come now let us reason together
seth the lord let us bow our heads and pray
dear god we thank you for this blessed occasion
in which you had a leading hand we thank you
to god for life we thank you for christ we
thank you for knowledge of your salvation
as i speak to those whom you love put your words
in my mouth their god put the spirit of christ
which is the spirit of humility in my heart
let me say only what you would have me to say
bless everyone under the sound of my voice
and all members of their families i pray
place your hand of mercy and provision on pure
light and let this institution be the reason why
multiply thousands are ready to meet christ when
he comes i pray in jesus name let god's people say
amen and amen genesis chapter 2 verse 15 the bible
says and the lord god took the man and put him
into the garden of eden to dress it and to keep it
ellen white writes in patriarchs and prophets page
50 paragraph one god appointed labor as a blessing
to man to occupy his mind to strengthen his body
and to develop his faculties to be a safe guard
against temptation and the source of happiness
let me go down the list to occupy his mind
laziness is not a part of god's system two
to develop his body three to strengthen his
body three to develop his faculties four as a
safeguard against temptation and five as a source
of happiness there's one that's not included now
let me tell you what that is in god's original
plan the purpose of work was not to earn money
let me allow that to sink in into minds that
are accustomed to earning money and expecting
money and there's nothing unbiblical about that
first timothy chapter 5 verse 17 verse 18 let
the elders that rule well be counted worthy
of double honor especially they who labor
in word and doctrine for it is
written or the scripture saith
thou shalt not muscle the ox that treadeth out the
corn and the laborer is worthy of his reward but
this system entered after sin and as a child
of god our highest aim must always be god's
system before sin and so i say again the
original purpose of work is not to earn money
it was to glorify god the bible says whether
therefore you eat or drink or whatsoever you do
and the expression whatsoever does not tolerate
exceptions whether therefore i was talking to a
a group sometime a couple of weeks ago and
i was commenting on first corinthians 10 31
whether therefore you eat or
drink or whatsoever you do
do all to the glory of god and
since i was in the united states
i said to the guys who were present there is
a spiritual way to play a game of basketball
and in south africa there's a spiritual way to
play a game of rugby or a glim of soccer now you
say to yourself this man is not well no i'm quite
well there is a spiritual way to do what we call
secular activities and so the bible says
whether therefore you eat or drink or work
do all to the glory of god there is no
exception to that spiritual standard
the original purpose of work uh in addition
to the list i gave you was one to glorify god
to to develop man into god's ideal for him even
in his sinless condition adam needed to develop
in the new world we will have to develop the
bible says they shall go forth and grow up
as calves of the stall malachi chapter 4 verse 2
development does not cease at the coming of christ
it continues because we're told by god's servant
higher than the highest human thought can reach
is god's ideal for his children godliness
when does that process end it never ends
god lightness part of that process of development
is work according to the quotation i gave you
uh desire of ages page 20 paragraph
2 you exist to serve someone else
let me say it again we exist to serve someone
else this was the attitude that christ brought
matthew 20 verse 28 even of the son of man
came not to be ministered unto finish the verse
but to minister in other words christ did not come
for himself in his high priestly prayer he said i
have glorified thee on the earth i have finished
the work which thou gavest me to do in john 8 29
jesus said he that have sent me is with me the
father hath not left me alone for i do always
without exception all ways the things that
please him or those things that please god
and so i must keep repeating you and i are
on this earth for the benefit of others
that amen is too weak you and i are on
this earth for the benefit of others
let us quickly look at the ten commandments
and i'm keeping aware of the time the first
four commandments outline our duty to god
the next six our duty to our fellow man
which one outlines our duty to ourselves
none there is nowhere in the bible where we're
called to love ourselves we're called to love god
and our neighbor now you may say well
shouldn't i go to school and get a phd
or go to pure light and get a masters yes go but
you get it in order to be more qualified to serve
service is the spirit of heaven
sacrificial service a young man spoke to me
a few years ago and he said i'd like to do
what you do travel the world self-supporting
evangelist then he said to me how will i eat
that was esau's problem how will i eat and he
solved that problem by giving up eternal life or
giving up their birthright giving up the spiritual
benefits the first concern of human beings
is always how will i eat or how will i survive
and so when the devil sought god's permission
to attempt job he went out he took away everything
job had and he came back and god said he hold the
that's his integrity although that moves me
against him to destroy him without a cause
and the devil said unto the lord skin for
skin all that a man hath will he give for his
life in serving god our lives
must not be our first concern
since you didn't hear me let me say it again
in serving god our lives must not be our first
concern the doing of the will of god when paul
in acts chapter 20 met with the ephesian elders
on his way to jerusalem paul told
them he knew he was going to die
he tells us in second timothy chapter 4
verse 6 for i am now ready to be offered
and my time the time of my departure
is at hand i am going to die for this
jesus christ came to die for us when he sent
out the disciples on one of the missions
he asked them in luke 22 35 and he said
unto them when i sent you without purse
or script which is a container
for food or shoes lack ye anything
did you lack the verse ends
this way and they said nothing
if god calls you to serve
he is obligated to provide
god is not obligated to you
he's obligated to his word
let me say that again god is not obligated
to us no human being or angelic being can
place god under obligation that is why the red
heifer represents christ it never wore a yoke
it is a it represents the lack or the absence
of obligation god is obligated to no one he is
obligated to his word because if he says it finish
my words he will do it and so as you consider
service as the brother said in the deserts of
namibia or the kalahari of botswana or the ice
of sweden or the waters of papua new guinea
wherever god sends you not where you send yourself
don't sit and say well paris needs
missionaries new york needs missionaries
london needs missionaries where everything
is close at hand let god choose the location
because he will choose a location that
has what you need my young graduates
of pure light training program on all those of you
listening when you commit yourselves to serve god
god commits himself to take care of you let me say
it again when you and i commit ourselves to serve
god and that commitment must be total jesus said
love the lord thy god with all thy heart with all
thy soul with all thy mind with all thy strength
this must be the commitment because the loy tells
us satan takes control of every mind that is not
decidedly under the control of the spirit of god
let me say that again there are some people 95
percent surrender to god that doesn't work satan
takes control of every mind that is not decidedly
under the control of the spirit of god mind
character and personality volume 1 page 13
paragraph 3 it's a frightening statement and
so jesus says look serve me with all your heart
with all your soul with all your mind with all
your strength with all your might with all your
understanding in that scenario there is not a um
a square inch of room for satan because it
has been given to god totally when you do that
god steps in provides protects blesses sustains
and multiplies your influence to degree
that you could never ever have imagined when god
calls you you know when god called me 20 years ago
the spirit said to me leave your job i
came to south africa and to uganda to speak
i went back to united states with about nine
invitations to come back i was working at a
hospital in a medical school as a counselor
and i sat at my desk reading an email from a
church somewhere in south africa the request was
said we need two crusades one in the spring one
in the fall send us your budget i wrote back i
have no time i have no leave because i'm working
instantly the spirit said to me leave the job then
you'll have all the time you need leave the job
and i said leave the job i'm making thousands of
dollars a year i'm respected by all the doctors
and and the students i leave the job the job was
everything that made me feel special leave the job
for a year the spirit said without adding
or subtracting a word leave the job
i spoke to a friend of mine a professor
of marketing at the university of michigan
my spiritual brother we're like this
whenever i have a spiritual crisis i call him
and i said david here's what i'm going through
i sat on his front step a sunday morning sun was
shining nice clear spring morning i believe it
was and uh he listened to me then he walked away
for a while and he came back and he said randy
i could not leave my job you have to leave yours
you have to leave and i leave the spirit said
leave the job leave the job leave so i left let
me tell you what happened to me when i made the
final decision to leave i went to the dean my
boss and i said dean i'd like a year's leave under
that arrangement you go away for a year from your
job you do whatever you like you come back to
the same job same benefits same salary she said
why i said i'd like to go away and do missionary
work for you she said okay i'll see if i can
get you a leave two weeks later she called me i
cannot give you leave if you leave the job is gone
i said to her dean i have to go she said
you're leaving this secure position i said
yes if i don't go i will never be able to live
with myself and so i left july of 2000 until now
i answer the question of christ just as the
disciples answered him in luke 22 35 when i
sent you without purse or script or shoes latchy
anything and my answer to god right now is no
god has taken me all over the world to places
i studied in geography class as a little boy
that i never thought i would see and every
time i land in a new country i remember
when a god said leave the job what i'm saying
to the graduates do not concern yourself
with how will i eat concern yourself with i desire
to do the will of god jesus said therefore i say
unto you take no thought for your life what you
shall eat or what you shall drink not yet for
your body what you shall put on it's not the
life more than meat and the body than remnant
behold the fowls of the air they so not
neither do they reap nor gather into barns
yet your heavenly father defeated them if your
father he didn't say their father feeds them
he said your father feeds them now if your father
feeds them surely your father should feed you
you and i are on this earth i closed the book as
a visual symbol of my impending conclusion you are
on this earth to serve others to be a blessing to
others there are people who will never come to god
through a sermon but they'll come when you apply
cabbage to their pains and eggs or charcoal
or hydrotherapy or a massage when that lifeless
limb starts to move when the pressure drops when
the pain vanishes mysteriously mysterious for
them but you will know exactly why when that
happens that person is listen is willing to listen
to whatever you have to say about the god who told
you how to remove their pain and so i say to
you go forth go forward under god's direction
let me close by saying this the bible says in
hebrews 11 29 by faith they pass through the
red sea as by dry land the verse ends this way
which the egyptians are saying to do were drowned
faith is not presumption god called the
israelites through the red sea he did not
call the egyptians the israelites came through
they were unscathed the egyptians came in and
they drowned every single one when god calls
you go when he doesn't call you don't move
but in order to know that god is calling you
you must be in contact with god every waking
moment amen psalm 32 8 i will instruct thee and
teach thee in the way which thou shalt go i will
guide you with mine psalm 25 4 show me thy ways
o lord teach me thy paths lead me in thy truth
ask god to do that along with constant surrender
and god will direct your path one other thing
there are things god already wants us
to do we already know that we do not do
and that blocks further transmissions from god
people come to me i want you to pray that god will
heal this and heal that i said do you return the
tithe no do that do you go to church no do that do
you study the bible no do what you know you ought
to do and then god is more willing to step in and
do for you what you cannot do for yourselves what
am i saying make sure there is no revealed duty
that you are ignoring because if you are
it will block further transmission from god
your god says he that is faithful in that
which is least is faithful also in much and
so may the lord bless your lives i mean it
from my heart do not ask how will i eat ask
how can i be faithful all you need to know is god
said leave the job once you identify the voice of
god act do not wait until every step is clear
god guides us one step at a time you see this
step and there's darkness for where the next step
is supposed to be god could have created the world
in uh one minute he did it in six days one day at
a time god sent manna one day at a time and god
expects you to trust him one step at a time not
one mile at a time one step and so recommit your
life to god without reservation identify his voice
by exposing yourself to his word this is his voice
each christian needs to identify god's voice for
himself or herself your wife cannot tell you what
god's voice is your husband can tell you yes god
speaks to us through others but you must arrive at
the point where you know that this is god's voice
because when god said leave the job friends and
family tried to dissuade me but i knew it was
god's voice and i close now by saying may the
lord bless you take you by the hand according
to hebrews 8 verse 9 take you by the hand and
guide you through service so that when he comes
people will walk up to you in the kingdom and say
it was because of your medical missionary service
that i am in god's kingdom can you say amen
let us pray father in heaven we thank you for
the honor of being called by you to work with you
father angels would love to do what you have given
us to do but that distinguished honor is reserved
for us i ask in the name of jesus christ who
himself according to ellen white was the highest
of all medical missionaries bless your daughter
and your three sons and inspire those who are
thinking of following a similar path use their
lives their god to be a blessing to those for
whom jesus christ shed his blood and for those
who've come to be part of this audience their god
let them go forth from this place having
rededicated their lives to god and to so live
with the consciousness that they are on this
earth in their neighborhoods in the workplace
in the classroom to be a blessing and
of service to others hear this humble
pray father save us when you come i pray in
jesus name let god's people say amen and amen
you